>>> JOINING US NOW FOR HIS
REACTION AND WHAT COMES NEXT,
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN BILL
KEATING OF THE STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS.
THANKS FOR TAKING THE TIME THIS
MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, JIM.
>> FIRST, THIS IS PART OF A
PATTERN HERE, RIGHT?
WE'VE SEEN THEM TAKEN TO A
NUMBER OF BLUE STATES, BLUE
CITIES.
FIRST, YOUR REACTION TO THESE
MIGRANTS BEING DROPPED OFF ON
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
>> I HAD A PERSONAL CALL
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON FROM A
MARTHA'S VINEYARD OFFICIAL.
THEY WERE TAKEN TOTALLY OFF
GUARD.
A PRIVATE CHARTERED PLANE,
EVIDENT THERE WERE TWO, NOT
CHEAP, WAS ON THE ISLAND AND
PROBABLY 50 -- FIRST PLANE 25,
NEXT PLANE MAYBE 25 PEOPLE WERE
THERE, AND THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO.
THEY HAD NO IDEA.
THEY REPORTED TO ME THAT THESE
PEOPLE GOT OFF THE PLANE, MEN,
WOMEN AND CHILDREN FROM
VENEZUELA, AS THEY TOLD ME.
THEY HAD A MAP OR INSTRUCTIONS
IN THEIR HAND WHERE THEY WOULD
GET HOUSING AND JOBS, AND IT WAS
A VACANT PARKING LOT, THE
DESTINATION.
WE CONTACTED OUR GOVERNOR IN
FACT, JIM.
THIS IS A TALE OF TWO GOVERNORS,
TWO REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS, ONE
WHO WAS USING TAXPAYER MONEY FOR
CHARTERED JETS AND HIS OWN VIDEO
PHOTOGRAPHER TO CAPTURE THIS FOR
HIS OWN POLITICAL BENEFIT,
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF WOMEN AND
CHILDREN, MEN, WHO DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE THEY WERE GOING, AND
ANOTHER GOVERNOR IN
MASSACHUSETTS THAT WE CONTACTED,
AND HIS OFFICE WHO PUT HIS NOSE
TO THE GRINDSTONE AND HAD HIS
AGENCIES SPRING INTO ACTION
ALONG WITH LOCAL OFFICIALS DEAL
WITH THE MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
>> THE GOVERNOR OF MASSACHUSETTS
IS REPUBLICAN WE SHOULD NOTE.
THE IMMEDIATE ISSUE HERE, CAN
LOCAL RESOURCES SUPPORT THESE
MIGRANTS THERE AND HOW AND FOR
HOW LONG?
>> THAT'S PART OF THE CYNICAL
NATURE OF THIS.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS A VERY
SMALL POPULATED ISLAND.
PEOPLE COMMUTE FROM THE LAND
JUST TO WORK THERE BECAUSE
THERE'S NO HOUSING.
SO THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH THIS, BUT
FORTUNATELY RELIGIOUS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND LOCAL OFFICIALS AND
NOW STATE OFFICIALS ARE
SPRINGING INTO ACTION TO DEAL
WITH IT.
THERE WAS NO ABILITY TO DO WITH
IT HERE.
THIS WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN A
DESTINATION SIMPLY TO MOVE THEM
FROM ONE STATE TO ANOTHER.
THIS WAS CLEARLY JUST TO ATTRACT
POLITICAL ATTENTION WITH AN
ISLAND THAT IS KNOWN IN THE
SUMMERTIME FOR ITS WEALTHY
VISITORS.
BUT I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU THIS,
THAT IT BACKFIRED ON HIM WITH
THE RESPONSE OF LOCAL OFFICIALS.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS, THOUGH,
THE WAY THE CURRENT LAW STANDS,
WHEN YOU HAVE FOLKS COME TO THE
BORDER, THEY APPLY FOR ASYLUM,
AS THEY'RE WAITING FOR THEIR
CASES TO BE HEARD, ADJUDICATED,
THEY CAN'T.
TRAVEL INSIDE THE U.S. AND OFTEN
DO ON THEIR OWN.
DOES THAT LAW NEED TO BE
CHANGED?
>> I THINK THE WHOLE SYSTEM
OBVIOUSLY, JIM, IS BROKEN, AND
WE COULD DEAL WITH ISSUES IF WE
COULD EVER GET TOGETHER,
PARTICULARLY ON THE SENATE SIDE
OF THINGS.
WE'RE NOT EVEN DEALING WITH
PEOPLE WHO WERE TAKEN HERE AS
CHILDREN, THE DACA CHILDREN, THE
DREAMERS WHO CAME HERE AND
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED OR IN THE
MILITARY, IN SCHOOL BY
DEFINITION.
SO REALLY, INSTEAD OF THESE
STUNTS, I HOPE WE CAN GET SOME
BIPARTISAN AND BICAMERAL HELP TO
DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM AND MOVE
THE THING FORWARD.
USING PEOPLE, USING THIS ISSUE
AS A POLITICAL WEDGE EVIDENT HAS
WORKED FOR A WHILE IN TERMS OF
POLITICS.
IT'S JUST NOT THE WAY TO TREAT
HUMAN BEINGS AND IT'S REALLY NOT
BEING RESPONSIBLE IF YOU PUT
YOUR HAND IN THE AIR AND TAKE AN
OATH AND HELP PEOPLE.
>> CONGRESSMAN BILL KEATING, I'M
SURE THIS IS AN ISSUE WE'LL
SPEAK ABOUT AGAIN.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
THIS MORNING.
REPUBLICANS MAKING A MIDTERM
CHOICE TO HIGHLIGHT ANOTHER
CRISIS THEY SAY IS THE
PRESIDENT'S SALT.
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS
SENDING TWO PLANES OF MIGRANTS
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
MIGUEL MARQUEZ IS THERE FOR US.
A SURPRISE ON THE ISLAND.
WHAT IS THE FALLOUT TODAY?
>> Reporter: A VERY BIG
SURPRISE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A CHURCH WHERE ALL 50 OF
THEM ARE BEING ASSISTED, GETTING
THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET RIGHT NOW.
I MET ONE WOMAN ON THAT PLANE.
SHE SAID YESTERDAY MORNING, THEY
WERE IN SAN ANTONIO.
SHE, HER HUSBAND, AND THEIR
CHILD.
AND THEY WERE PROMISED HELP.
THEY SAID THEY WERE GETTING ON A
PLANE, THEY WERE PROMISED HELP.
SHE, HER FAMILY, AND 47 OTHERS
GOT ON TO TWO PLANES NEAR SAN
ANTONIO.
AND THEY ENDED UP HERE IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
I WANT TO BRING IN DILLON
FERNANDEZ, A STATE
REPRESENTATIVE HERE.
YOU'VE BEEN CHATTING WITH FOLKS.
HOW ARE THEY DOING HERE AND WHAT
NEEDS ARE BEING MET?
>> SURE.
EVERYONE'S NEEDS ARE BEING MET
RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE TO MOVE OVER SO THE
PERSON CAN COME THROUGH HERE.
EVERYONE'S NEEDS, THE SECOND
THEY GOT OFF THE PLANE WERE MET.
THIS ISLAND COMMUNITY SPRANG
TOGETHER.
EVERYONE GOT THE BEDS AND THE
SHELTER.
WE HAVE AREAS SET UP, TRIAGE
AREAS WITH SPANISH-SPEAKING
ATTORNEYS.
WE HAVE A PLAY ROOM FOR THE
CHILDREN THAT IS SET UP.
THERE'S KIDS HERE.
>> Reporter: SEVEN FAMILIES.
FOUR CHILDREN BETWEEN THE AGES
OF 3 AND 8.
THE WOMAN I SPOKE TO EARLIER
SAID HER CASE, HER NEXT
APPOINTMENT IS IN SAN ANTONIO IN
A MONTH OR SO ON A REFUGEE
STATUS BECAUSE SHE HAS CLAIMED
REFUGEE STATUS, HER FAMILY.
HOW IS THIS GOING TO WORK?
THIS IS MORE COMPLICATED THAN
GETTING THEM TO THE MAINLAND AND
GETTING THEM TO SOME SHELTER IN
MASSACHUSETTS OR ELSEWHERE.
>> THAT'S WHAT THE ATTORNEYS ARE
WORKING ON RIGHT NOW.
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE MOST
IMMEDIATE APPOINTMENTS FIRST.
WORKING WITH THEM TO RESCHEDULE
OR FIND A WAY TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN.
IT'S AN ONGOING SITUATION.
>> Reporter: THE AIRPORT SAID
THEY HAD 20 MINUTES TO PREPARE
FOR THE PLANES COMING.
YOU THINK THIS IS IT?
THEY HAVE MADE THEIR POINT?
>> THE POINT HERE IS, IS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO -- WE HAVE SEEN
THIS HERE TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO COME TOGETHER AND
SUPPORT WHOEVER SHOWS UP HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE THE FOOD, WATER AND
SHELTER THEY NEED.
RON DeSANTIS AND REPUBLICANS
MIGHT WANT TO PLAY POLITICAL
GAMES WITH PEOPLE'S LIVES.
I THINK THAT'S INHUMANE TO BE
USING WOMEN AND CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES, AS A POLITIC AL PAWN.
YOU'LL END UP TALKING ON TUCKER
CARLSON.
WHAT IS REALLY TOUGH AND BOLD,
IS THE PEOPLE COMING HERE
TOGETHER ON ISLAND TO SUPPORT
THESE FAMILIES.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
IT.
>> Reporter: THEY COVERED THE
SEPARATION FAMILY POLICY UNDER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
IT WAS DIFFICULT TO SEE THE
FAMILIES TORN APART.
DO YOU SEE THIS AS A
CONTINUATION OF THIS IN THAT
REALM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE'S NO LOW THESE PEOPLE WILL
GO.
THEY WILL KEEP GOING LOWER AND
LOWER.
AND THEY'RE WILLING TO USE
HUMANS.
CHILDREN, WOMEN, FAMILIES, AS
POLITICAL PAWNS FOR THEIR OWN
GAIN.
IT IS DEPRAVED.
IT IS EVIL.
IT IS WRONG.
WHAT MAKES AMERICA GREAT IS WHAT
WE SEE HERE TODAY, WHICH IS AN
ISLAND COMMUNITY AND A STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS, COMING TOGETHER
TO SUPPORT THE PEOPLE HERE.
>> Reporter: SIR, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
JOHN, BACK TO YOU.
THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT FOR THE
STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS IS COMING
HERE, AS WELL.
TO HELP COORDINATE A LOT OF THE
CARE FOR THE PEOPLE FROM TODAY
AND FORWARD.
BACK TO YOU.
>> MIGUEL, BEFORE I LET YOU GO.
I DON'T KNOW THE PHYSICAL
RESTRAINTS THERE.
CAN YOU WALK AROUND, TO THE
DEGREE YOU WALK AROUND A LITTLE
BIT, TO GIVE US THE SCOPE.
I'VE BEEN TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
MANY TIMES.
I KNOW WHERE YOU ARE.
JUST SO OUR VIEWERS CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS BEING DONE
HERE.
>> Reporter: THE CHURCH IS
ACROSS THE STREET FROM WHAT YOU
ARE LOOKING AT NOW.
THIS IS THE PARISH HOUSE.
THERE'S A ROOM WHERE THE KIDS
ARE.
THEY WERE PLAYING VOLLEYBALL OR
SOCCER BACK THERE A LITTLE WHILE
AGO.
MOST OF THEM ARE VOLUNTEERS.
SOME OF THEM ARE IMMIGRANTS WHO
ARRIVED HERE YESTERDAY.
THEY ARE SETTING UP TABLES TO
RECEIVE GOODS.
THEY HAVE TONS OF VOLUNTEERS TO
BRING PEOPLE IN, SO THAT THEY
CAN HELP OUT WITH EVERYTHING
GOING FORWARD.
THERE IS ANOTHER CHURCH IN TOWN,
ALL OF THEM ARE BEING HELD AT
ONE LOCATION OR BEING HELPED AT
ONE LOCATION NOW.
THERE'S ANOTHER CHURCH IF MORE
ARRIVE, THEY ARE MAKING
ARRANGEMENTS FOR THAT.
THE SENSE OF PULLING TOGETHER IS
REAL HERE.
IT'S HELPINGFUL AFTER THE HIGH
SUMMER SEASON.
THERE'S FEWER PEOPLE HERE.
IT'S A TOWN THAT GOES TO 20,000
PEOPLE IN THE WINTERTIME.
AND OVER 100,000 PEOPLE DURING
THE SUMMER.
THEY ARE STEPPING UP TO FILL THE
VOID.
>> MIGUEL MARQUEZ, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP THERE.
THE DECENCY AND THE COMPASSION
OF PEOPLE COMING TOGETHER TO
HELP FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS.